at launch Ghost Recon breakpoint was
busted and kinda boring it got written
off by a bunch of people and rightly so
but what if I told you in the five years
since release it has become one of the
best Ghost Recon games of all time and
an excellent open world game hello and
welcome to Gamespot no HUD the show
where we take a look at some of your
favorite games and tweak the settings
just enough to create a brand new
experience today we're taking a look at
Ghost Recon breakpoint and we're going
to turn this into the Tactical tense
shooter that we all wanted now this is
going to be a tough Mission so we've
recruited deep Ghost Recon expert to
guide us along the way
all right
[Music]
break point built upon 2017's Ghost
Recon wildlands as another open world
Ghost Recon game however instead of
refining its Co-op sandbox and the
Tactical opportunities it presented
breakpoint buried those core ideas under
a loot-based shooter with color-coded
loot gear scores and even raids yes they
put raids in a ghost recon game while
the moment-to-moment gameplay was nearly
identical to wildlands the blue grind
not only compromised the identity of
Ghost Recon but also poisoned the entire
experience for many the pitch was a
tactical shooter with survival mechanics
some of which were interesting others of
which felt underdeveloped the delivery
however was an underwhelming Ghost Recon
game that abandoned ITS Tactical roots
in favor of chasing Trends with a poorly
implemented live surface model it was a
disaster from top to bottom but this is
a Redemption story
so how do we turn this mess into one of
the best tactical Shooters on the market
we'll take you through the process to
show you how we'll be incorporating
tweaks and new features that ubisoft's
own patches introduced before taking
matters into our own hands with a mod
that is going to rework The Experience
significantly and will have deep explain
what the impact of this is
I got him thankfully Ubisoft did some of
the heavy lifting back in 2020 when it
introduced something called ghost
experience parameters yes it's really
called ghost experience parameters this
update allowed players to hop in the
settings menu and rebalance the entire
game in a matter of seconds more
importantly you can even turn off the
terrible gear score and loot system
altogether which we're gonna do right
now I've got nothing against loot
systems I've played my fair share of
Destiny and they can offer a rewarding
Loop but they don't belong in a ghost
recon game what Elite operative is
constantly changing their clothes and
tossing away equipment for new ones that
incrementally make them feel more
powerful none the answer is none so
where do we go from here well this is
where deep comes in he's put in over 600
hours in breakpoint and he doesn't just
play this game he makes it sing
it has to be extreme I have the Tactical
difficulty put up to Elite and the
interface the whole HUD is pretty much
nothing I don't have Anna hang up except
for the objective that I'm going to just
because if I don't have guided mode on I
will go on the tangent and I will get
lost it's pretty much Bare Bones zero
HUD and just a little bit of guidance
from the game well this show is called
no HUD so I guess it makes sense just to
turn basically everything off like Steve
said the only thing I'm going to leave
on are the objective markers so I don't
get lost or distracted however when
watching Deep's gameplay I did notice
one important HUD element missing
reticles yeah no Crosshair which was a
learning experience but I feel like the
more I play it I'm looking for more and
more of a challenge and to be more
immersed and yeah across hair was
breaking the immersion for me at a
little bit so I got rid of it this may
seem daunting even a bit absurd for a
third person shooter with
over-the-shoulder aiming but breakpoint
provides you with the tools to overcome
this the obvious choice is to turn off
over the shoulder aiming altogether this
means that aiming will default to iron
sights and Scopes if you prefer the
over-the-shoulder style of aiming you
can track down a laser sight that said
if you've never played breakpoint before
I don't recommend turning everything off
right out of the gate now the gameplay
experience will be predominantly defined
by the Tactical difficulty menu here you
can tweak a wide range of settings that
can fundamentally change the game the
biggest example of this is gear score
which we've already turned off while div
said he doesn't typically play
breakpoint like a survival game he does
set the Tactical difficulty to Elite at
least is a starting point this means
bandages are limited risk of injury is
set to always the stamina consumption is
Extreme health does not regenerate and
ammo is lost on reloads additionally
syringes don't heal injuries if that
wasn't enough darkest night mode is also
turned on meaning visibility is reduced
at night this hopefully will force us to
use our night vision goggles more okay
let's pause here for just one second I
need to emphasize that we're not trying
to make Ghost Recon breakpoint as hard
as possible instead we're trying to make
it the most tense tactical shooter it
can possibly be of course for some
people the fun is in making the overall
experience more punishing but for others
these settings promote that thoughtful
play style it's all about finding your
sweet spot so when you fire up
breakpoint to revisit it I suggest you
play around with these parameters and
see what fits your play style some of
these settings even lean more to the
survival aspect that gives more purpose
to some of breakpoint's more extraneous
mechanics like drinking water and
cooking
thank you
now a key component of every good
tactical shooter is difficulty and enemy
AI enemies should be aggressive
responsive and deadly this forces you to
play smart and think multiple steps
ahead if the AI lacks in any of these
areas the gameplay can devolve into a
super soldier shooting gallery which
isn't the Ghost Recon way the best
tactical Shooters reward careful
planning as much as quick judgment calls
and unfortunately even on break points
harder difficulties you can rip through
enemies and outposts without giving it
much of a second thought there's not a
lot of risk unless you are severely
underprepared thankfully the Ghost Recon
Community has already addressed this
issue with the Spartan mode mod one of
the coolest things it does is it beefs
up the perception of the enemy AI which
I think that a lot of people who have
played on Extreme for long enough will
complain that the AI don't really
respond as much as they should to things
going on around them this mod isn't
technically a new difficulty mode the
modder who goes by andar describes it as
a rebalancing that tweaks enemy Behavior
this mod also makes it particularly
difficult to take down a base during the
daytime which makes sense since they'll
have better visibility during the day
vandar recommends setting the enemy
difficulty to the second hardest
difficulty Advance rather than the
hardest Elite given the ai's improved
awareness elite can be particularly
brutal borderlining on unfair when you
load up breakpoint after making all of
these changes it feels like a very
different game and in a sense it is the
minimal HUD forces you to pay more
attention to your surroundings and
listen for nearby threats the inability
to Mark enemies requires you to keep a
mental map of the area information
typically available to the player is
stripped away so that the Intel
Gathering and strategic considerations
that Define the Ghost Recon experience
return to the foreground it's impossible
to know how many foes are patrolling a
point of Interest unless you do some
actual Ghost Recon even the topography
time of day and weather needs to be
considered when you play This Way
mountain ranges can give you better
sight lines to gather information and
pick off stray enemies if you have the
range while valleys could leave you
exposed in a precarious position time of
day especially with darkest night mode
enabled as well as weather can also
significantly hinder your visibility
which could be used to your advantage if
you take a stealthy approach or a
detriment if you allow the mission to
devolve into an all-out uncontrolled
firefight
foreign
reconnaissance and careful coordination
pays off in dividends when playing this
way planning and orchestrating a
successful attack based on your own
Intel that you had to uncover yourself
is incredibly satisfying it slows down
the overall pace of the game but it
makes encounters feel more meaningful
throughout that said I do think turning
off the HUD wholesale can be pretty
off-putting especially for those that
may not be familiar with all of ghost
recon's mechanics without pickup markers
you probably won't be able to tell loot
from environmental dressing and without
a detection indicator it can be very
hard to tell where an enemy spots you
from thankfully nearly every little HUD
detail can be customized I suggest
starting with light or minimal interface
presets and then customize from there as
you get more comfortable at the very
least I turn off the health bar ammo
counter and minimap the red vignette
makes it pretty obvious when you're low
on health and your character will limp
if they are injured if you leave
objective markers and waypoints on
however you can get by without the
mini-map entirely if you're playing
Co-op though you may want to leave the
compass on with a minimal HUD this makes
coordination more intense as it forces
you and your buddies to accurately call
out cardinal directions rather than
relying on red flips
[Music]
while chatting with diff one thing he
said stuck out to me the ability to be
methodical be tactical just kind of
living out the fantasy of being you know
a special spec opposition I feel like
Ghost Recon lets you explore these
opportunities with your imagination a
bit more it's interesting that we have
that option to express a bit more of our
preferences our our own identity within
breakpoint I think what's most
surprising is that with all these
settings whether intentional or not
Elevate breakpoint Beyond an open world
tactical shooter it almost scratches a
role-playing itch that I never expected
in a game like Ghost Recon sure there's
different classes and skill trees but by
the end I had unintentionally created a
backstory and personality for my
character that informed my play style
it's rare to see this kind of
flexibility when it comes to Modern game
design but in the case of Ghost Recon
breakpoint it recontextualizes the
entire experience and therein lies the
beauty of breakpoint and also the point
of no HUD this show is about finding new
and interesting ways to play games Ghost
Recon breakpoint players were dealt a
bad hand when the game was released but
with the changes we've suggested you can
lay all its cards on the table rearrange
them and play with a deck of your own
creation Ghost Recon breakpoint is more
than just a pretty island with guns it's
a Sandbox brimming with possibility and
honestly the more I think about it I I
think it's safe to say that Ghost Recon
breakpoint earns the Tom Clancy Ghost
Recon name
thanks again for checking out this
episode of no HUD if there's games you'd
like to see us cover in the future make
sure to let us know in the comments
below and hey while you're down there
let me know how you play Ghost Recon
breakpoint I'd love to know I'll see you
next time